[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bienvenue à parole
Dupuis cette semaine je pense que je ne
surprends absolument pas personne en
vous disant que la nouvelle de
l'actualité c'est le fait que pour la
première fois à l'Assemblée nationale
une femme autochtone a été élu on se
rappelle qu'un homme il a été élu en
2007 c'est Alexis wanada qui avait gagné
en représentant le Parti québécois mais
cette année 15 ans plus tard ça va juste
prix 15 ans on sait que maintenant c'est
Katy riche champagne Jourdain qui
représentait la CAQ qui a été élu dans
Du Plessis c'est un énorme changement
pour le paysage politique québécois mais
aussi pour le paysage politique
autochtone on se rappelle que cette
année il y a eu des un nombre record de
candidats autochtones à travers ces neuf
candidats ben seulement un a été une a
été élu excusez-moi
ça change beaucoup de choses ça va
changer beaucoup de choses autant que
quand
était devenu ministre avec le
gouvernement libéral on se rappelle que
la lecture des
d'une personne autochtone qui
représentante justement dans un parti
politique élu avec deux niveaux
politiquement il y a le niveau
autochtone puis aussi le niveau à
l'octobre le niveau de politique
québécoise celle qui fait partie du
quotidien mais le fait d'être autochtone
amène un autre charge une autre charge
excusez-moi qui est celle du droit
d'autochtone du droit ancestral de la
représentativité d'une nation c'est
beaucoup de choses qui vont amener à
être discuté à être changé à être
échangé aussi parce qu'on va demander à
où où se porte des allégeances qui veut
te représente en premier on se rappelle
que pour jodellin c'était vraiment de
représenter sa communauté qui
primordiale avant son rôle qui était
officiel parce qu'elle dit je ne serais
je pense qu'il y avait dit si je serai
toujours autochtone après même quand je
n'aurai plus ce rôle donc ça va être
extrêmement intéressant ça va être aussi
très difficile à voir parce que
on s'entend que c'est un milieu qui est
difficile le milieu politique québécois
n'importe quel dans n'importe quel
province mais on rajoute en plus le fait
d'être autochtone on va demander parfois
à des personnes qui sont racisées
autochtones qui sont tous Spirit d'avoir
un niveau d'excellence des fois qui
supplante celui de n'importe qui au
quotidien parce que comme première
représentante féminine autochtone on va
regarder encore plus on va scruter
encore plus ces gestes ces actions mais
elle a quand même éclatée le plafond
vert et ça c'est pas peu dire donc c'est
extrêmement intéressant il faut rester à
l'affût des nouvelles aussi de comment
le traitement de catégorie
champagne-jourdain en tant que
politicienne va être mis de l'avant
est-ce qu'on va justement lui mettre des
accusations ou des poids puis ça je
parle autant du côté autochtone que à
l'automne sur ses décisions du fait
qu'elle est Inoue du fait qu'elle vienne
une communauté toutes ces choses-là vont
être extrêmement intéressantes et aussi
très nouvelle je pense dans la lecture
politique au Québec ça existe déjà dans
l'Ouest canadien mais au Québec c'est
quand même une nouveauté et on s'entend
qu'il y a quand même aussi une
différence dans la manière de faire la
politique au Québec qui affecte aussi la
manière de faire de la politique
autochtone ok au Québec donc intéressant
d'avenir on l'a félicite d'avoir éclaté
le plafond de verre et on lui souhaite
la meilleure des chances et en espérant
que justement on n'attendra pas un autre
15 ans pour avoir un autre élu ce
fauteuil ou soit-il une femme ou un
homme autochtone donc je vous souhaite
une belle semaine c'est quand même une
semaine assez
intéressante post réconciliation ça
change quand même quelque chose et ça y
met une lumière de sport alors je vous
souhaite une belle semaine